good morning John good morning Hank it's
time for the quadratic on are you liking
your chances ah medium I mean if I were
up against anyone but you I wouldn't
like them at all
a scared I remember when I was a young
man my mama took me to the store and I
stared out of my mind as I stared at
that dressing room door I was like what
if the passer dude likes you dark tea
bag into like
I really know how croquet works I think
you just go through the wickets okay
nothing you miss huh
it's my turn now no no my turn now
you hit the ball and nothing happened oh
my god I wanted to do okay good work oh
that's through that's not through nope
Oh
it's got left your felt suggested a
spitting contest I'm not going to spit
spit though because it's gross
these halves pitiful things in them
apple seeds next round typing quiz who
types fastest feel pretty confident I
also don't do not feel good about this
round I'm usually at over a hundred but
I've had a few drinks good luck to you
Hank okay right go three two one I got
it right at the end Hank from the future
here the first vent in the quadratic on
as we said in John's video was the blue
seal competition when we filmed this
stuff John's video hadn't been uploaded
yet so we didn't know who had won the
blue steel competition it turns out
thank you all very much I did I buy like
a two-to-one margin at least I'm gonna
go ahead and give myself another point
and we're gonna play the last event in
the quad DragonCon are you good to poor
or bad I'm not good okay good perfect oh
no that's terrible news for me is this
tiny little stick I managed to tape my
balls as far as I can
Bittan real close here at the end this
is basically all of quadriga con
probably go
that happen that's a that's my rule
strategy is to have someone else screw
up the 8-ball I will say one thing for
me that eight-ball scratched rule it's
not a real rule it's just a rule that
we've always happened to play by gonna
be the actual official rules the thing I
did was not the end of the game but as
brothers we have always played that if
you've got to the 8-ball you lose the
game so anyway that was quadratic on
2015 I guess I don't mind tying with you
John I mean I look I do a little bit it
was really great to spend some time with
you in the family to do some stuff
together I miss you already I'll see you
on Tuesday because I wanted one a lot
for the next week you can pre-order up
quad DragonCon 2015 shirt and then never
again so that's something that you can
do oh my god what wha no points for
style